hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff and yes you read the title
correctly
it is something that we have never seen
before but uh
that we we definitely need to see so
we're continuing with the 1858 clash
between paul charles murphy and thomas
wilson barnes and
this game is uh well uh i'm not gonna
say better than the previous ones it's
not
worse it's just it's just out there
they're just brawling it out and
i enjoyed it immensely so uh here it is
without further ado morphe goes for e4
barnes replies with e5 as he usually
does and morphe goes for f4
so for now we have the king's gambit on
the board but barnes declines the gambit
with bishop to c5
and morphe continues simply developing
knight to f3 going after the pawn here
and
barnes now defends it with the d6 but
now
now we reach the position from the
thumbnail and here we have it b4 the
so-called
kings evans gambit it's uh crazy crazy
stuff uh with this b4 move uh morphe of
course fights for the center
but also for honor uh as he wants this
just bishop captures and then he can
bust open with d4 but barnes is not no
stranger to
the value of the center so he just goes
back bishop to b6 keeping an eye on the
d4 square
and while morphy could go bishop here to
to go fight after the d4 square once
again he
goes for bishop to c4 he wants to have
some threats
very early on and next he will go some
like c3 d4 or maybe bishop here and then
d4 and then hopefully castle for the
moment castles uh
is off limits uh but barnes knows that
uh
well uh you do not want to allow any
tactics here like bishop captures knight
here and you want to castle as soon as
possible so this is what barnes does he
goes knight to f6
uh prepares the castle and now there
there is no funny business here and
while morphy could go for f captures on
e5 he doesn't like
knight captures on e4 so first he
defends it with queen to e2
but now knight to c6 barnes just
continues developing and adds another
defender to the center
uh we have c3 by morphe now with ids of
d4 in the future and
barnes just castles and now you can see
that uh
even though morphe played the king's
gambit he went for the king's evans
gamble with that b4 move
uh it's uh actually barnes who who is
better developed and his king is already
castle to safety so by
not accepting any of morphe spawns
button just barnes
just has a really really nice position
so here morphe goes d3
uh strength in the center and now he
will have to figure out how to develop
as castling is still off limit so maybe
some bishop to e3 to counter this bishop
but we'll see barnes goes e captures on
f4
he doesn't allow bishop to e3 so now he
forces morphe to capture
and this is a problem for morphy because
after bishop captures an f4 now barnes
busts open with the d5 now uh that this
pawn this has been uh completed
uh the rook can also come to e8 and it
could be very dangerous as morphe's king
is still in the center of the board
so morphe of morphe of course not uh
want to open up the center while his
king still occupies the e1 square he
goes bishop back to b3
and now d captures an e4 by barnes and
now d
captures an e4 and here we reach a
position that
uh well it's a very it's very it's
incredible to even imagine
that the player with the black pieces
does not take advantage of so feel free
to pause the video and
find the the winning idea for barnes
here while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh uh for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations on spotting the
immediate and crushing knight captures
on e4
that's also for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show but
uh barnes didn't play this and this is
crushing because you're
you keep the king in the center of the
board the bishop still cuts off this
diagonal
there's not much you can play here if
you go for uh for this grab here then
rook e8 is deadly and yes you can block
with knight e5 let's say captures
captures
but now queen g5 and you have this
threat you have this threat uh well
obviously the rook wants to capture you
have a queen to c1 check thread the
bishop still
slices over this diagonal it's like uh i
mean this is
uh it's just insane
so uh in this position knight captures
an e4 game over
uh but barnes goes for bishop to g4 he
he just keeps improving the position
so it's really weird uh how oh this guy
barnes i mean i
i i just don't get what's his deal and
it's not that he blundered anything his
position is still better
uh but knight captures and e4 was just
you know crushing on the spot
uh here he allows knight beat to d2 for
morphe to cover some very
very uh important squares he goes knight
to h5 now going after morphy's bishop
and now he wants to get the other knight
into the game so morphy goes back bishop
e3 counters
barnes bishop on b6 and now knight to e5
putting more pressure on the f3 knight
here
and now morphe just castles queen side
and from that position where knight
could have captured an e4 and and ended
the game
now it's uh you know it now it's uh
black is still better but
when you play against morphe it can
still be anyone's game so here barnes
goes with the immediate knight to d3
check uh of course morphy has to move
the king king c2 now there's the threat
of just queen captures knight
and now he just shift this knight over
here guarding this knight and also
attacking the queen so
murphy needs to get rid of one of the
knights he plays bishop captures on f4
with knight captures again attacking the
queen and queen f1 now
the knight covers these two squares the
bishop still slices over
still a very very impressive position
for barnes so queen to e7
preparing to bring the other rook into
the game so h3
pushing the bishop back bishop h5 and
now g4
we have bishop to g6 and excellent
bishop on this diagonal so of course
morphy moves the king king to b2 and now
while you could play bishop captures on
e4
then morphy tricks you with rookie one
and uh you you're just gonna lose a
piece here
and even if you didn't lose a piece you
you just don't give up the bishop for a
night here
even if you win a pawn especially not in
1858 you don't do it nowadays but in
1858 no way you do this
so rook 8 to d8 barnes starts uh
bringing the
final two rooks into the game and now
knight to d4 by morphy
now he says okay i'm i'm about to play
knight to f5 here which will either
force you to leave my knight there it's
going to be an excellent piece on f5 or
you're going to capture and i'm going to
open up the g file
and start an attack against your king so
bishop captures on d4
barnes doesn't allow the knights to land
on f5
but now queen captures an f4 by morphy
but now comes
bishop to e5 attacking morphy's queen
queen to e3
and now barnes with the fancy stuff
queen captures on b4 as the pawn is
pinned you cannot capture here
and what what do you play here for
morphe well morphy says
that's very nice however there aren't
any threads here so i'm just going to
continue attacking with h4
and okay barnes says i do not want to
see h5 on the board so he plays h5
and now comes knight to c4 attacking the
bishop here
and now the problem is if barnes goes
back to keep the bishop on this diagonal
e5 is deadly here
now you white is just winning because if
you move the bishop the queen can be
captured you no longer control this
diagonal
so after knight c4 barnes went back uh
with queen to e7 but now uh morphy
trades down rook captures with rook
captures and
g captures on h5 now uh opening up some
some lines here with bishop captures an
h5 uh
bishop captures on e4 is a little bit
better when the bishop captures on e4
uh you don't uh concede to anything and
of course queen captures is impossible
due to bishop captures on c3 check and
morphy loses the queen
however barnes went for bishop captures
on h5 and now he allows morphe this very
interesting queen g5 move attacking the
bishop here
uh putting a double attack on the bishop
here and allowing him to trade queen so
you can see that
pretty much in every game uh morphe is
almost
struggling to trade queens against
barnes as barnes is one fierce attacker
so barnes has to trade here otherwise
you will lose one of the bishops so we
have captures captures and now again
there's the trouble of the two bishops
being under attack but barnes
finds bishop to f3 we have rooked f1 by
morphy and now bishop to e2 with a
double attack
and this is how barnes wiggles out of
the attack and now while it would be
reasonable for morphy to play some like
rook f2 captures captures and play this
game
uh barnes is up a pawn but it's uh
bishops of opposite colors and with
uh well with all with all due respect
towards uh mr barnes's uh uh end game
skills uh i doubt he would
be able to to get more than a draw here
against morphy however
morphy said uh i'm not interested in
playing something like this i'm going to
give up the rook and play for this
and try and win this game because
i'm paul morphy that's how i roll so
bishop captures on f1
barnes accepts the challenge and now
even g6 before capturing on f7 now
setting up a deadly threat here of
course uh the pawn cannot be captured
and the bishop is unable to help out
so king of f8 barnes gets out of the
nasty uh nasty
diagonal and now g captures on f7 now
the f7 pawn is defended and if bishop
knight g6 lands with check it's game
over so barnes defense rook here guards
the g6 square but now
knight back to f3 preparing knight g5 to
here with check so rook the f6
put puts an attack on the knight and now
knight the g5 by morphe and here comes
rook to f2 with check first king a3
and now c5 preparing c4 as the bishop
covers that
to get some pressure away from the f7
pawn
uh and here the problem is uh knight the
e6 check no longer works here because
after king captures you don't have a
good discovery you can't connect with
the rook or with the bishop or anything
so you have to settle for something like
this discovered check and after the king
moves you could
ch capture this and yes you have some
past pawns it's it's
it is a thing however g5 and the black's
past pawn is much much faster
so after this c5 move by barnes morphe
goes for bishop d5 now he attacks this
but now comes
uh b5 and now uh well
a5 is coming and it's just going to be a
tough position for white to play
here we have knight the h7 check uh
morphy says okay
i mean i don't have a better plan so i
might as well win back my exchange so
knight to h7 with
check king to e7 and now comes uh f8
with queen
you could try to go for something like
e5 and e6 to create two connected pass
pawns
uh well morphe decides to go for f8
queen and just a trade immediately
so rook captures we have knight captures
king captures and now
e5 which makes sense you want to control
all of these squares so the black king
cannot cross
however the problem is g5 and this g
pawn is again
extremely fast so here uh of course
the g2 square is already covered so if
you allow g4 it's game over just g3 g2
and that's it so morphe quickly goes
bishop to f3 to guard the g4 square but
barnes
just plays bishop to h3 it's not uh you
know not a great mystery you have to
cover these two squares and then the
pawn can just be escorted down the board
and that's it
so here we have c4 uh sorry c4 by white
uh now preparing uh
to either push this and then the morphe
can get the king into the game or
captures which is what happened in the
game but still king b2 and now you can
go king c3 maybe gobble up the pawns and
then
continue the game that way so here
barnes continues
g4 attacks the bishop bishop to d5 and
now
g3 morphe brings the king closer with
king to c3
and now uh feel free to pause the video
and win this game for
black while i give you a couple of
seconds
now uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on knowing your
end game and for those of you that
decided to play
g2 again shame on you because this is
exactly where morphe wanted to trick
barnes
g2 doesn't work for a very very simple
reason uh because
after the bishop is given for the pawn
and bishop captures you get queen
captures the king captures on c4
the c5 pawn is lost and it doesn't
matter what black plays now
you get this position and black's only
pawn is of the wrong color so black has
a light square bishop
a1 is a dark square even if white
removes both of
both of these pawns from the board uh
the white king can just
hide on the a1 square and the the light
square bishop will never be able to push
the the king away
so this is a well-known draw and this is
what morphe goes for barnes uh
not uh not interested in getting tricked
like this just goes bishop to e6
so congratulations to everyone who
played anything other than g2
so bishop to e6 uh now of course if
captures then there is no stopping the
pawn
and also very interesting if you let's
say captures on c4 then black can also
just trick you with this because the
bishop is now
pinned you cannot uh you cannot move it
so here after bishop b6 morphe still
controls the g2 square
but now barn starts bringing the king
into the game king e7
with a3 now bishop d7 checking to see
what morphe will do bishop d5
barnes repeats once and now bishop back
to f3
and now king to d7 uh here we have king
to d2
uh morphy needs to get the king at least
the here
so when barnes pushes g2 amorphy can
play king to f2 and at least guard the
pawn with the king
so bishop back to h3 guarding this g2
square and now king to e3
now it's not a problem now the king is
in time if the pawn is pushed
so king e6 by barnes but now bishop to
e2
going after this pawn but here uh here
uh just uh c3 was played and
it was in this position that paul
charles murphy resigned the game and
yet another excellent victory for uh
thomas wilson barnes against
the legend himself paul murphy you could
also play g2 here but
then like we said the king can come to
f2 and then you have to you know
still work for your meal this way with
c3 you just overloaded
both the king and the bishop and that's
just it uh you you have to prevent c2
and after it'll sound like bishop b1
now you're gonna capture on e5 you're
gonna play g2 the king will have to stop
it and then you're
gonna bring your king here push c2 and
win the game so very very
straightforward
and of course morphe knows this and he
resigned here
so it was really a crazy game first
barnes had a crushing victory then
morphy wiggled out and then morphy
had the option of just trading it down
into a drawn end game but morphe did not
want to draw he wanted to beat barnes
but barnes
then when morphy finally gave him a
second or a third or a fourth chance
came
came for fourth and was able to take
down
uh paul charles murphy so really really
awesome stuff uh i still don't have uh
any uh mr barnes t-shirts ready for you
but they are coming so you know
uh be be prepared so uh that's uh the
game i do hope you enjoyed it and of
course
happy international chess day everyone
uh i would like to thank gabriel says
uh andrew nicholson uh
anuchi tanuku uh thomas lindstrom uh
anish manikandan and
uh for contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the paul
morphy saga checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world tomorrow we
start the tournament of legends
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day